the group of Democrats looking to
replace the president is a little bigger
this morning former Massachusetts
governor Deval Patrick is launching a
campaign he released this video this
morning nearly a year after saying he
would not run I admire and respect the
candidates in the Democratic field they
bring a richness of ideas and experience
and a depth of character that makes me
proud to be a Democrat but if the
character the candidates is an issue in
every election this time it's about the
character of the country Patrick will go
to New Hampshire today to add his name
to the ballot for the 2020 primary there
with this announcement he will no longer
be a CBS News contributor at O'Keefe is
covering campaign 2020 and why is
Patrick entering now this late in the
game well Anthony he apparently thinks
there's still room for one more he told
us on this broadcast last month he
doesn't think former Vice President Joe
Biden is cutting it and now he plans to
run as a moderate who can bring his
party and the country back together the
63 year old served two terms as
Massachusetts governor the first
african-american to do so and the only
Democrat to hold the job this century
but it's the work he did before and
after his time as governor that's likely
to raise questions he once served as the
top lawyer at the oil company Texaco and
most recently worked for the private
equity firm Bain Capital that could draw
scrutiny from those critical of
corporate wealth and how big oil
companies contribute to climate change
how Patrick can quickly build up a
campaign raise the millions of dollars
needed and make it into the debates
remains unclear no one in the modern era
has ever entered the race for president
this late in the game and prevailed and
another potential candidate is former
New York City Mayor Michael Bloomberg do
we know if he's made a decision yet and
do you think the Patrick decision
affects this well we'll see but he has
not yet decided whether the run CBS News
has learned however that Bloomberg
will not file paperwork to appear on the
ballot in New Hampshire which holds the
first primary in February if he runs
Bloomberg is instead expected to focus
on winning contests being held on Super
Tuesday on March 3rd that's why he's
already filed to appear on the ballot in
Alabama and Arkansas and is working on
getting on the ballot in Tennessee
okay and thank you